ascribing a negative or positive label
to an emotional state is in my opinion
the biggest plight of the youngest
generation you want to draw a line and
say any feeling below the line is bad
it's like looking at the sky and saying
sunny days are good rainy days are bad
but they are both required for the earth
to continue as humans The Human
Experience is the breadth of the
experiences not just everything to the
left of the line which is why you have
these over-medicated kids who think that
any bad feeling is bad or rather any
feeling that they would prefer not to
have as something that they should not
have rather than a corrective tool to
get them back on the path that they want
to be on